I'm immensely proud to stand before you
the Carnegie Mellon University
graduating class of 2017
in my charge to you the graduates I wish
to focus on two themes the number four
especially focusing on the last four
years of your presence here and some
thoughts and suggestions for your career
and life beyond Carnegie Mellon
University four years
that's an interesting interval of time
every 40 years we see a u.s.
presidential election Olympic Games a
Soccer World Cup and of course a leap
year four years ago in the summer of
2013 you arrived on this campus as
freshman accompanied by your family
members
I had the enormous privilege and honor
of welcoming you to CMU at the
orientation event on the mall I told you
in your parents at the time that like
you I had just arrived on campus as a
freshman to begin the journey with you
how many of you remember that in the
succeeding four years you have
accomplished much in your learning your
field of specialization in your personal
growth in your teamwork
I need your global perspectives you have
built valuable relationships with your
mentors and advisors staff across campus
faculty members department heads Dean
coaches alumni and trustees you've also
contributed so much to the fabric of
this university and its rich heritage as
you walk the corridors of various
buildings then take the friends store
the cut push the buggy at carnival or
exhibit at your enormous crea
a billion technological prowess in
formal classroom work in theater music
and art in research in poetry and in
presentations you produced and exhibited
on campus your determination to improve
the human condition and your compassion
and humanity came through in the
numerous community service activities
you initiated and executed locally and
around the world
my wife Mary or I were privileged to
host many of you on hundreds of
occasions on campus and at our residence
our for conversations
entertainment meals and social
interactions and we came to see you not
just as students but as members of our
family we celebrated major achievements
together and we came together to hold
and support one another during times of
deep sorrow and tragedy while our
faculty continued to garner
international recognition for the
research and creativity you our
graduates today have also accomplished
much in these four years excelling in
athletics creating artificial
intelligence programs that defeated four
of the world's best professional poker
players in a marathon 20 day poker
competition winning the Putnam
competition the premier mathematics
competition for undergraduate students
in North America competing against the
best undergraduate math students in the
country during your time here your
accomplishments helped the University
scale new heights thanks to the
generosity of about 450 donors and the
efforts of many members of the CMU
community the last 40 years saw an
historic buildup of dedicated endowment
to support students through presidential
fellowships and scholarships this
program just established three years ago
has grown to benefit a total of 255
students this year
in every college and school at Carnegie
Mellon similar efforts were created to
support faculty through endowed
professorships your ideas and exuberant
engagement help the university establish
an historic expansion of the campus to
benefit generations of students in
teaching learning and research all this
was fuelled by one of the most sustained
and successful fundraising efforts in a
continuous four-year period the
university has witnessed this happen as
the university's visibility expanded
around the world from pioneering
university participation at the Tony
Awards on Broadway to faculty engagement
at the World Economic Forum in Davos to
hosting the President of the United
States on our campus and to attracting
several large multinational companies to
Pittsburgh while at the same time we
nurtured and supported our activities at
CMU campuses around the world your work
at the university community also brought
to the fore the critical need to enhance
the CMU experience for all this
commitment has already produced
initiatives and action plans for the
next several years to improve programs
and infrastructure for counseling
mentoring and enhancing student support
and services we have accomplished all
this together in close partnerships with
faculty and staff parents families
friends coaches trustees and alumni
today we pause to reflect and celebrate
as well as recognize and express our
pride in what you have accomplished in
your four years and I today I challenge
you yet again what will you do in the
next four years as you go out into the
world in whatever you do as a Carnegie
Mellon graduate you have joined over
100,000 living alumni we know that you
will be enormous ly successful and
impactful if history is any indication
many of you will occupy leadership roles
where your principles and values will
determine the scale of your impact if
you are a change agent your world will
be changing even faster than ever before
because of the accelerating pace of
change around the world if you are
someone who through hard work and
aspiration tirelessly seeks to improve
status quo it is imperative that you had
hired adhere to your principles even in
the face of obstacles adversity and
setbacks especially created by those who
are uncomfortable with the disruptions
that emerge from changing the status quo
Rosalyn Carter once said a leader takes
people where they want to go a great
leader takes people where they ought to
go even if they do not want to go there
such leaders make great personal
sacrifices to move their organizations
or their countries to a much higher
level against incredible odds and
opposition you may make some mistakes
along the way but you will learn from it
and be a better person and a better
leader never be hesitant to voice your
opinion Sir Winston Churchill was
famously said when the Eagles are silent
the parrots begin to jabber be an eagle
not a parent consider the case of
Abraham Lincoln who many historians
consider the greatest president of the
United States Lincoln who led our
country in the middle of the Civil War
established the Morrill land-grant Act
in 1862 that completely transformed the
higher education system of the u.s. his
signing of the Emancipation Proclamation
during a bloody civil war that throws
the country apart On January 1 1863 as a
presidential executive order changed our
society forever
also in 1863 Lincoln established the
National Academy
of Sciences with a remarkable vision
that was free of political influence
Lincoln faced resistance during his
entire leadership tenure another iconic
leader of our time spent a speech that
captures this theme because of the way
it played out as I read his code try to
guess to whom it is attributed the code
goes like this
there will always be dissident voices
expressing opposition without
alternatives finding fault but never
favored perceiving gloom on every side
and seeking influence without
responsibility that was a speech that
President John F Kennedy was supposed to
deliver in Dallas on November 22nd 1963
these words were in his prepared remarks
and he never had a chance to deliver his
speech my charge to you is do the right
thing based on principles values hard
work honesty and integrity as graduates
entering a new world facing new
challenges it is your duty to ensure
that faith use does not overwhelm truth
noise does not drown out the signal and
mere superficial Styles does not replace
deep substance with a CMU degree you are
well-prepared to separate signal from
noise facts from fiction and evidence
from a mere innuendo as you accomplish
much we expect you to return to this
campus sharing your knowledge and
experiences whatever you do wherever you
live you will have a profound impact on
the world a cook equipped with a CMU
degree I cannot wait to see how you
change the world
you were my freshman class and therefore
you are my special class of students
forever with whom I have bonded
with whom I bonded so much over the past
four years I will always be connected
with you
congratulations class of 2017
[Applause]